Scarlett there is a historical
relationship between Hong Kong and
Beijing yeah people don't really
understand it those of those of us who
think about Hong Kong often think back
to the relationship that Hong Kong had
the different relationship but it was at
a British rule yes how much has changed
in 17 years a lot has changed in 70
years officially speaking they have a
one country two systems model which
basically gives Hong Kong a lot of
autonomy they can pursue their
capitalists markets and all that but in
practice things have come together a lot
more in the last couple of years Hong
Kong people of late feel kind of crowded
out of their own city by the mainland
Chinese it's not just the air pollution
that's choking them but you also have
this introduction of Chinese national
education into the Hong Kong school
system which caused its own protests two
years ago along with the fact that Prada
stores are taking over every street
corner and catering to mainland tourists
mainland Chinese tourists and it makes
people feel as if they don't have a
space in their own home so this is a
natural outgrowth of that along with the
most recent dispute which is over the
democratic elections Hong Kong people
want universal suffrage Beijing has said
no we will allow you to elect someone
that we have vetted only prevent from a
select list of camp that's right by a
pro Beijing committee so what's the most
likely outcome here as we set up the
onset they're not going to stop until
their demands are met what's the likely
outcome well people are fear of fearing
that it would be something close to 1989
the hope is that it will go there
correct exactly the hope is won't go
there but in the next couple of days I
might get worse before it gets better
only because the protesters have
identified October first as a day to
renew their protests October first is
the 65th anniversary of the founding of
the people's republic of china every
year they have a big fireworks display
the trend the Hong Kong government has
already cancelled this year's fireworks
display in anticipation maybe
acknowledgment implicit as it may be
that things will not go off as usual
this year does the central government in
Beijing have a tricky line to walk but
yeah I mean what it wants to demonstrate
internally and what it inevitably ends
up demonstrated sextury absolutely I
mean as Richard Haass puts a Beijing
does so it needs to be really careful on
how it does this and want it doesn't
want to stoke the fires instead of
precedent for anyone else in the region
in Greater China not just
in the mainland shirt Jennifer exactly
in Macau anywhere else in the china
sphere they don't want to give anyone
any ideas on the other hand you crack
down too hard and we all know what can
happen so it's definitely a development
that will continue to watch but remember
also historically students student-led
protests play a very important role in
modern Chinese politics there's a soft
spot among Chinese people for
student-led protests there the
presumptive elite right we have the
ability to gain the support of other
social groups and we've all seen what
happened in 1989 so it's they're very
idealistic people especially after
seeing the tear gas have felt that maybe
you know they're on the side of